gibt es die wahre liebe philipp du
meinst im leben in der literatur
überhaupt sag mal ich würde es auf allen
feldern bringt bejahen was ist denn die
wahre liebe
ich glaube die wahre liebe hat schon
auch sehr viele aspekte die in dem buch
tatsächlich vorkommen nämlich dass man
auf eine art eine leidenschaft hat und
eine zuneigung die sehr starke und auch
ein verantwortungsgefühl für den anderen
so jetzt kann man sich ja fragen wie
interessant ist die wahre liebe für die
literatur oder ist die wahre liebe
vielleicht auch tragische liebe das ist
etwas was zu den bands in seinem neuen
roman die einzige geschichte eigentlich
sagt kroll 18 jähriger jüngling lernt in
den 60er jahren in der nähe von london
eine sehr viel ältere frau kennen und
zwischen diesen beiden entflammt eine
amour fou und sie sagt sich von ihrem
mann und ihren beiden kindern quasi los
und geht mit ihm nach london in ein haus
und dann beginnt das vergehen der liebe
es gibt zum beispiel eine szene wo sie
quasi ihre familie verlässt und er
findet das richtig cool weil er denkt
aha das ist jetzt die wahre liebe dass
die frau die familie verlässt und sie
ist aber gar nicht glücklich darüber
befinde es bleibt immer ein moment von
selbst fixiert hat ich finde die figur
ist auch sehr selbstmitleidig gegen ende
hin 119 glaubt er die liebe ist stärker
als andere und eine lektion quasi die ja
auch reflektiert ist dass das eben nicht
so ich finde liebesromane dürfen auch
echt weh tun und schrecklich seien
düster furchtbar schrecklich dass
verfallen sein und die sehnsucht und all
diese dinge dieses leidenschaftliche das
finde ich daneben schon in der literatur
auch sehr interessant wobei es sehr
schwierig ist über die liebe kitschfrei
zu schreiben ich finde
julian barnes löst das ganz meisterhaft
in dem er einen wechsel der
erzählperspektive vornimmt wir fangen
hier in dem buch in der ersten personen
wegen uns über die zweite person in
richtung dritte person das heißt die
distanz wird immer größer im dritten
teil wo es dann wirklich ganz übel wird
da denkt man sich auch immer da will
auch der erzähler nicht dabei gewesen
sein als das alles passiert ist ich
finde eigentlich dass der julien baums
da und auch sehr nahe kommt das ist
schon eine ziemlich umfassende wahre
liebe die er da schildert ich habe die
wahre liebe schon lange lange
gefunden scheint noch nicht verloren
wieder nein die wahre liebe entwickelt
sich ja auch von tag zugenommen immer
weiter genau das ist ja das schöne und
gibt mir recht zwischen uns das wahre
liebe es zwar ein so wundervolles
schlusswort stopp aus
[Musik]